so you know there's this candidate
running against Joe Biden not Marianne
Williamson not the dark psychic energy
I'm talking about
Robert Kennedy Jr
RFK Jr had been banned from Instagram
and Facebook his Facebook which owns
Instagram Has Lifted that ban
why had he been banned well because RFK
Jr is skeptical of the medical
establishment and he thinks vaccines are
often harmful and he thought kovid was
essentially a big hoax and you
previously were not allowed to say that
on a lot of social media including
Instagram
now Instagram says okay he's back
he's back that's fine YouTube just came
out
and and YouTube announced that they are
no longer going to censor people for
saying that
the 2020 election was obviously Rife
with fraud
I'm still hedging my bets a little bit
so I don't I don't want to make a
declarative statement I'm just observing
that the new YouTube policy is that
the 2020 election was transparently
obviously Rife with fraud and we all
know it
maybe I stepped over the line there I
don't know but YouTube's saying we're
not going to take you down for saying
that anymore
okay great why
that's so strange
[Music]
we're heading into an election year huh
there are two reasons I think why big
Tech is starting to lighten up on some
of the censorship of conservatives the
first one is Twitter
that's the one the rest of big Tech
didn't count on which is that Elon Musk
was going to buy Twitter and that he was
actually going to be able to for now at
least withstand the forces of censoring
conservatives and he's going to make it
basically a free speech platform or at
the very least
reinstitute normal standards of speech
so don't suppress the conservatives I
don't think they were counting on that I
think they're afraid that Twitter has a
real opportunity to gain some market
share there and so Neda and Google and
alphabet you know Facebook and and
Google and YouTube are starting to
loosen up for that reason the other
reason though
that's that was the rosy reason the the
more
I don't know doer cynical pessimistic
reason I think is that those issues just
don't really matter anymore
oh yeah you can talk about vaccines you
can talk about the lockdowns and all the
fake covid science yeah because we
already did it we already did covid we
already locked it all down we already
made you inject yourselves with that
experimental drug we are yeah okay we
already got you fired from your job
you got you kicked out of your school
okay and now now the evidence is out and
you're going to talk about the evidence
about how a lot of what we said wasn't
true yeah okay fine
yeah oops Whoopsie Daisy okay yeah you
got us right we're moving on to issues
that matter now
the 2020 election
yeah that's who cares that's over we did
it yeah we did it we we got we got
whatever strategies we wanted whatever
new voting rules we wanted even if they
were in contravention of state
constitutions like in Pennsylvania yeah
we did it and then the election happened
and then people fought about it but then
Biden's been president now for a couple
of years
yeah okay you can talk about how there
was a lot of fraud fun doesn't matter
because we're moving on to the next
thing
what's the next thing the next thing is
obviously
can I I don't even know if I can say
the word I don't on big Tech can I even
say the word you know that you know that
ideology
that says that if you're one
type of human being you might secretly
be a different type of human being
like you might if you're one
if you're like the kind of person who
has like a big Adam's apple and a beard
that you might secretly be the kind of
person
that has like rounder hips and
gives birth you know that idea I don't
even I don't even want to say it because
they're clamping down on it so hard
you know which one I'm talking about
that's the new stuff
Pride
the sexual Revolution
the redefinition of family
the redefinition the reordering of
Education to support this new view of
family
all that's
the new thing and that's what they're
going to censor you for that's what they
already are censoring you for that's
going to be a bigger deal
conservatives often are fighting the
last battle okay well this is the new
battle and that's why the libs they're
loosening up on the last battle because
that one's already won
now they're moving on
to this one right now go to Helix
sleep.com with everything going on in
the world right now you could really use
a good night's sleep that is why you
need to check out Helix mattress he
likes his harness to use extensive
mattress expertise to bring their
customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years now I absolutely
adore the mattress night after night I
sleep like a sweet sweet baby and I want
the same for you Helix says a sleep quiz
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you buy a mattress
made for someone else go to
helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz to find
the perfect mattress for your body and
sleep type their flexible payment plans
make it so their great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for my listeners hurry on over to Helix
sleep.com Knowles with helix better
sleep starts now right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles a company that I am
very proud to stand behind and a company
that's proud to stand behind us over
here in our country is pure talk veteran
owned with a 100 American Workforce
puretalk shares our beliefs our vision
for the country that is why Pure Talk is
the official cell phone wireless
provider for the daily wire that's not
the only reason Pure Talk also happens
to be the most Dependable 5G Network in
the United States you're going to hear
that you know what you're going to hear
it's one of the it's not it's the best
this is a top tier provider at a
fraction of the cost of those other woke
companies ATT Verizon T-Mobile
companies that don't care about you or
your values are worse seek to undermine
them in fact you can get unlimited talk
text and unlimited data with a mobile
hotspot for just 55 a month I promise
you that it's cheaper than what you were
paying now for all those things you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting leftist wireless companies
that don't support you go to
puretalk.com nulls you get great
coverage and save while you're doing it
go to puretalk.com Knowles you'll save
an additional 50 5-0 off your first
month because they actually value you
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans by Americans
speaking of conspiracies
and conspiracy theories this is a story
I have to get to
because of my colleague because of my
friend Mr Walsh
okay here we go for this from the
debrief which I had never heard of
before but this is the headline in the
debrief intelligence officials say U.S
has retrieved craft of non-human origin
here we go here's our monthly
ET story
here's our monthly leak from the
government from an anonymous source that
actually ignore what they're doing in
your schools and ignore the southern
border like the actual aliens entering
our country and ignore no there's a
spooky UFO look up there look at that
butterfly up there yeah
a Former Intelligence official turned
whistleblower has given Congress and the
intelligence Community Inspector General
extensive classified information about
deeply covered programs that he says
possess retrieved intact and partially
intact craft of non-human origin
okay he goes on and explains why
he's convinced this is ET it says
analysis is determined that the objects
retrieved are of exotic origin non-human
intelligence whether extraterrestrial or
An Origin based on the vehicle
morphologies and material science
Testing and the possession of unique
Atomic arrangements and radiological
signatures okay
nah no that's not real
that's just not real one I don't really
believe Anonymous leagues coming out of
the government at convenient times just
generally but you put that aside for a
second
how do they know this is non-human
origin
how do we how do you know it wasn't just
the Chinese who made it furthermore how
do we know that this is not just a fake
out to hide our technology that maybe
has been
observed by hostile powers to pretend
that this kind of technology is not
really our technology
how do we know that this Anonymous top
intelligence official how do we know
that this spook this professional liar
is not just pulling a fast one which is
literally his and their jobs to do
don't really buy it
why else do I think the aliens are not
real because they are
if there is anything that kind of
resembles aliens in the world
and this is a hard pill to swallow and
they're demons okay they're demons
aliens almost certainly do not exist
there's zero evidence whatsoever for
aliens existing but the universe is
really big yeah that doesn't
have any implication whatsoever for the
likelihood or unlikelhood of aliens
existing we don't know what the origin
of life is as a material cause
we do know the formal cause of of the
origin of life but that's a conversation
for another day
we do we
well no it's a conversation for right
now actually inasmuch as we do know the
spiritual
aspect of the origin of life
okay we
Drive our life as a gift from God
in terms of the exact mechanics of how
that happened
biologically and many many years ago we
don't know that exactly
which is why we don't know it we have no
reason to believe that it could or would
crop up anywhere else but furthermore
because we know that spiritual reality
metaphysical reality exists we know
there's a moral order we know that there
there are intelligible things in the
universe we're using signs to
communicate about things that are not
merely material right now that's what
we're doing because we know that there's
good and bad we know there's love and
joy and Hope and Dreams and all those
things we know that there is such a
thing as Spirit we know that we're not
just bags of chemicals
all right there's something immaterial
about us as well
demons and angels are just Spirit
they're pure spirit
in the way that an inanimate object
doesn't have a soul right it's inanimate
doesn't have anima soul
uh there are also things that are purely
spirit and we are both
we're rational souls and bodies in a
hylomorphic being
and aliens are the fevered
fantasies
of even people who are generally right
about a great many things
even people such as my poor friend Matt
Walsh has fallen under this way
of the absolute inanity of the alien
phenomenon boy what a great clip that
was make sure you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time